les amis c'est quand même qu'on fait une
émission autour des voyages c'est notre
thématique dans renversant et vous ne
faites un album qui s'appelle parisienne
exactement
mais pourquoi alors bas simplement parce
que je suis de châtelet les halles pour
tous tenir la barre de paris le le
ventre de paris le ventre de paris
exactement mon père est né à châtelet ma
grand mère aussi
et j'avais envie voilà de rendre hommage
entre guillemets à cette identité qui
est la mienne qui est paris mais je veux
dire je suis parisienne à tokyo ou
parisienne à istanbul enfin voila c'est
c'était aussi ce que juste pas pour
montrer ce que j'étais devenu en fait et
tout mes inspirations à ce nouveau riche
et le grand et c'est ma manière d'écrire
aussi c'est presque aussi un album tout
aurait pu s'appeler parisien parce que
toi je vanille tu viens apparaît depuis
quelques temps maintenant ça doit faire
incompétente en a quand même et les
temps passe vite
tout à l'heure on posait la question à
ben lui qui a voyagé à los angeles aux
racines de la salle du groupe justement
il nous disait on a besoin de revenir
aussi de se trouver un point d'ancrage
est ce que paris c'est pas aussi votre
point d'ancrage vous qui avez l'habitude
de jouer à travers le monde
ben moi ma maison c'est môm'artre et
quartiers de paris et je ne me sens à la
maison qu un moment est ce que ces
influences toi ton d'état création
complètement
bah oui il sait plus de la moitié de ma
vie mais c'est aussi beaucoup plus de la
moitié de mes racines je dirais de mes
influences mes racines c'est mes racines
mes influences bas c'est plus à paris
que ça s'est joué que ronnie taylor je
suis italien parce que je le suis cette
année tu as mais c'est sûr que je crois
même que je parle des italiens avec un
peu d'accent français parfois maintenant
un accent par eskom ont parlé des
racines italiennes vous allez faire
l'album intermezzo qui était aussi une
ode à l'italie il m'a coaché à ce que
moi j'ai failli tenir un école mais je
me suis trompé italien je comprends
maintenant se confiant à mesure des
tournées voilà souvent on tournait qu un
contrebassiste italien donc ils se
parlaient ensemble avec jeu tu as senti
exclu un peu a pas du tout je compromets
j'ai au contraire augmenter mon
vocabulaire enfin voila j'ai ouvert en
cabinet mais du coup quand je manie m'a
proposé de faire cet album de duo de
chansons italiennes
il m'a coaché forcément sur l'accent
italien et elle a pas il m'a dit ça va
tu en accent du sud de milan ça passe
et donc du coup voilà on a fait cet
album qui est et qui en fait ma permis
c'est un trait d'union pour me permettre
aussi de travailler ma technique vocale
encore plus parce que les chansons
italiennes
je veux dire fois il est vraiment tu
peux pas y aller en demi mesure quoi il
faut vraiment travailler est ce qu'on
appelle le belting aussi et du coup ça
m'a inspiré pour écrire ce nouvel album
parisienne alors souvent la musique sort
très facilement et c'est après la
musique qui me parlent et qui me dit si
ça va être en français ou en anglais
donc j'ai un petit côté jeanne d'arc je
sais mais je l'assumé complètement et
sur l'album en fait c'est arrivé que par
moment la musique me parle dans les deux
langues
et donc il ya une même musique pour deux
textes différents mais comment comment
vous faites alors pour vous lancer dans
une chanson est ce que ça commence au
piano alors ça dépend à 80 surnom
souvent je le laisse faire
en fait ça dépend c'est à dire que il a
pas l'air d'accord avec six mois ça j'ai
dit non non monsieur sur un même nom
mais c'est à dire que en fait sur les
albums précédents
giovanni m'a dit ce que tu composes oui
mais je m'assume est pas totalement il
m'a dit en voyant une chanson il est en
tournée au japon en ce moment là je lui
envoie je mets mon téléphone quand à sur
le piano je m'enregistre est tout et il
me dit c'est génial ce que tu peux m'en
écrire dix autres comme ça mais bon
c'est que je suis sur le bon chemin et à
partir de là en fait comme je te dis le
piano m'aide beaucoup à composer à est
en fait c'est chouette parce que des
fois on coécrit avec giovanni nous on
voit des trucs avec le téléphone qu on
s'enregistre pendant qu'on juge souter
vocale alors souvent il n'y a pas de
titre ces genres numéro 3 178 10 c'est
sympa et puis mes dit mais c'est pas toi
qui fais la compa voilà un papy le dîner
la musique te parlera à la musique tu
diras et tu écriras d'ailleurs ça marche
bien
d'où ce bonne nuit les